que riadh sidaoui politologue et
directeur du centre arabe de recherche
et d'analysé politique et sociale
bonsoir y at il un oui merci d'être avec
nous alors la présence un dur
gn à cette vidéo conférence est-ce que
c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle
oui bon puisque le problème doit être à
arabo arabe s'est elle construit entre
des libyens il y à des traités au sein
de la ligue arabe pour intervenir
protéger un état en difficulté ou en été
envahi et en libye aujourd'hui on a une
armée turque l'armée turque a envahi
militairement la libye afin d'aider les
troupes perdante sur les troupes de fait
savage qui ont perdu plusieurs batailles
alors pour changer la donne militaire
l'armée turque est là l'armée turque à
mon avis rats présentent l'auto elle ne
peut pas entrer en libye sans le soutien
et le feu vert de washington des
américains la libye riche en pétrole en
gaz donc on peut pas leur offrir comme
ça autour de l'autre côté il ya l'armée
égyptienne l'armée égyptienne au ciel et
forte puissante
le président égyptien a déclaré devant
ses généraux si c'est la ligne rouge
siens
si les taux auxquels et les troupes de
l'ouest franchissent syrte
on va revenir mais les termes en est
massivement est une menace directe et
quand on voit la carte qui viennent on
voit que sir cette ville partage la
libye en deux la libye de l'ouest la
libye de l'est historiquement c'est la
cyrénaïque à l'est la tripolitaine à
l'ouest il ya aussi ne faisait donc le
sud donc aujourd'hui la majorité des
paysages sont en faveur de l'ess de
castin de l'armée nationale libyenne qui
se compose en majorité écrasante des ex
officiers soldats de l'armée de kadhafi
sont souvent reprenait et 11 ont étudié
dans les académies militaires de l'union
soviétique
c'est peut-être pour cette raison aussi
que le russe se tiennent cette armée
nationale libyenne
mais la donne militaire a été changée
par une intervention étrangère si c'est
la grande question qui se pose
aujourd'hui en libye et l'appel de la
ligue arabe
peut-il être entendu
vous à mon avis jusqu'à nouvel ordre
actuellement c'est le militaire qui
prime qui primait le politique mais
peut-être parce qu'il ya une rencontre
entre les chiffres d'affairé comme un
général américain et fait sa rage à
l'ouest de la libye
peut-être les américaines vont demander
au tueur que vous ne devez jamais
franchir la ligne rouge ça veut dire
s'il est de cette façon peut faire après
un certain compromis politique ou une
union nationale mais le grand problème
des libyens ce sont les interventions
étrangères
ça veut dire si chaque partie demande
l'aide et le soutien d'une puissance
étrangère évidemment les nationalismes
league est très affaibli actuellement
par des partis politiques sont composés
rapidement et après 2011
n'oublions pas aussi que la libye à la
situation actuelle en libye résulte de
quoi de la situation de 2011 parce que
l'automne quand il a frappé la libye et
la casse est à la fois le régime de
kadhafi le gouvernement de gafisa fille
mais l'état l'état libyenne ça veut dire
son armée nationale ses services secrets
sa police nationale doit vite un grand
vide institutionnel qui a été rempli par
des milices des ministres souvent
extrémistes se vend même des proches
d'al quaida la libye est devenue un
bastion aussi des terroristes que ce
soit de neige déjà bateau nostra
d'al-qaïda dans sa série à
on nous donne nous savons aujourd'hui
qu'avec l'intervention l'intervention
turque aussi il est peut-être des
centaines ou même des milliers déjà 10
des terroristes qui viennent de la syrie
lui à la turquie donc la situation
actuelle libyennes menacent directement
la sécurité en algérie la sécurité en
tunisie il a su faire interner en egypte
l'armée algérienne a déplacé ses troupes
à la frontière avec la libye la même
chose l'armée tunisienne la même chose
l'armée les biens et donc c'est une
situation très grave puisqu'il ya des
armes qui circulent partout et des
groupes extrémistes
le maréchal à tarare et ils vont
vraiment fâché fragilisés selon vous
quelle est
son avenir oui parce qu'il a perdu les
dernières batailles militaires mais
aussi il ya des excuses
hélas hélas confrontés l'armée turque et
l'armée turque est sophistiqué steen
c'est un penny ailier de l'otan l'armée
turque que l armée de khalifa haftar se
compose comme j'ai dit de l'ex majorité
ce sont les l'ex armée nationale de
gueddafi peut-être lierre peut-être lui
aura des changements au sein du
commandement militaire née dans tous les
cas je pense que il y a une tendance à
vraiment à diviser la libye a partagé la
libye entre l'est et l'ouest
il veut le partage de la libye est ce
que ces lotos les états unis d'amérique
que ça veut dire ni vainqueur ni vaincu
ça veut dire qu'à l'image n'a pas le
droit de devenir un bismarck libyen la
libye pas la force et vice versa si les
feuilles sauvages n'a pas le droit de
franchir si tu n'as pas devoir d'aller à
la l'est est arrivé à la frontière
égyptienne donc initié la libye la libye
doit être restés divisés partagé en deux
est et ouest merci à riadh sidaoui
d'avoir été avec nous nous avons apporté
votre analyse